hey everyone welcome back to how to
Hollywood I'm your host Kristen Gill and
today I have celebrity makeup artist
Rihanna's day 100 G makeup artist Queen
milah Morales here with me today thanks
for having me I'm so happy to be here
today we also have fellow eg online host
Courtney tez know here it's a beautiful
Courtney yes she was our model so tell
me what you're going to be doing the
Courtney okay so today we're doing
Rihanna's signature red lip that we've
been doing for many years along with a
beautiful golden eye a really hot lash
and to tie it all in her signature glowy
skin
okay I've started by prepping the skin
with foundation concealer powder bronzer
and of course blush just to give her a
peachy glow I'm gonna start with the
eyes first as you can see we've already
applied her lashes and I used this new
brand called demure lashes I want to
start with a peachy orange neutral tone
just to give her a little bit of depth
increase in her crease area just to warm
it up and here I'm using the Anastasia
color palette subculture and their new
palette II and after I warm up the eye
I'm gonna start with applying her crease
to give it definition my favorite memory
of working with you on it obviously
there's so many because we've been
together for so long it's just being
able to travel the world and
experiencing new cultures being able to
like work with some of the best
photographers and directors you know all
over the world what inspires me is the
fashion without the fashion there's
really no other way to apply the makeup
because with that it's important for us
to like understand what she's wearing
the whole look of the whole thing
because then that leaves me
to like create the palette my favorite
set to be on is a fashion shoe editorial
just because the days are a little
shorter than then normal but I really do
love to do editorial and you know
fashion shoots just because it's so much
fun we get to look at the clothes it's
different every single time so it just
leaves room for just for us to play
creating the glowy eye with Anastasia's
liquid glow it's what we use for
highlighter but I like to use it on the
eyes just because it's a creamy
eyeshadow when apply it on the eyes
definitely can layer eyeshadow on top in
this case like let's say you're you know
like doing a red carpet you want to just
apply a little bit of a powder just so
that you know you have staying power
I've done bold red lips and I've done
like a smoky eye it just depends on like
I said the fashion and the outfit or you
know what we're doing and then after
this I'm just gonna apply a gold powder
just to set the shadow what's your vibe
like getting ready with Rihanna you guys
taking shots like what are you doing
oh no she wouldn't look half as yeah no
we're actually just really mellow like
listen to music and talk a lot em but
it's just you know like glam glam time
is like kind of like our sort of Zen
moment you know before all the chaos so
we met on the set of a video shoot that
was it
that was the beginning of our love
affair
now I'm just gonna go back with that
brown shade just to give it a little bit
of a crease again just because I went
over it with such a gold highlighter
when doing a red lip I want to start out
with like a lip liner and here I'm using
red from Mac and today I'm doing a matte
liquid lipstick but I still like to use
lip liner as well
I actually don't cover the entire lip
just because the liquid matte is really
really intense already but the the lip
liner just gives it more of a definition
so here I'm using the NARS power matte
lip pigment and it's really really like
it's not so drying which is really
important when you're using a liquid
matte because what happens is it'll tend
to clump
and I like to apply it in the corners of
the eyes just to give it a pop you want
to take the same highlighter and just
define the Cupid's bow the same brush
and this is how we've created Rihanna
signature lip damn is another wedding
shine and which just keep it wedding
black as if I'm your sister thank you so
much for being here my love thank you
for having me yes girl and thank you
Kourtney for being our beautiful model
and make sure you follow milah on social
media make sure to LIKE and subscribe to
entertainment tonight's youtube channel
and come back every Sunday for a new
how-to Hollywood
let us know in the comments down below
and what you want to see next bye guys
bye